[Music]
foreign
you think your wife can hear you
no
iBall
Maybe I'm Wrong
maybe not goodbye to you my trusted
friend
a new day is Dawning
new ideas no rules no management we've
known each other since
who is this
challenge him to single combat with a
loose it's a way out
I don't sit at the table your family
does please pray for me
please
[Music]
man has to look his best when it's time
to get married
or buried I'm going to need a gun
goodbye my friend
[Music]
if you win
the table will honor its word
we'll have your freedom
laws only one can survive
failure to meet at sunrise
results in execution
Last Words Winston
I want you to find your peace but the
good death only comes after good life
you and I left a good life behind a long
time ago my friend
[Music]
this hit
goes out to you Mr Wick
Ed 42 regular wasn't it yeah
and so it begins
challenge him to single combat if you
win you'll have your freedom
amen
the only way John Wick will ever have
freedom
and peace
[Music]
yeah not really
yourself
have you given any thought to where this
ends
the table will never stop
without this
no one
but not even you
kill everyone
thank you
ready John
[Music]
foreign